évidemment il faut s'inquiéter il faut
s'inquiéter parce qu'il ya trois
solutions le je tiens à vous dire que je
suis
inquiet parce qu'il ne faut pas penser
que le dérapage du nucléaire je n'ai pas
possible j'ai beaucoup géré pendant la
guerre froide les crises et vous
comprenez il suffit d'avoir une
interprétation mauvaise le glauque à
classique d'ailleurs c'est la mise en
alerte des millions de russes avaient
des forces de dissuasion russe que vous
ne savez pas j'ai mené l enquête il ya
quelques jours byden il dit j'ai deux
solutions
soit
la guerre mondiale soit les sanctions
mais l'occident n'est pas comprendre
c'est les sanctions sévères et c'est du
aulas là et là deux solutions et dix
minutes après il n'est pas au contraire
une mauvaise interprétation
et en plus il fait comprendre qu'elle
serait validé si on permettait
briguerait poutine psychorigide mais qui
ressemble à staline et je travaillais
avec brejnev et vous comprenez byden que
j'ai connue autrefois qui était un très
bon sénateur mais simplement l'étagé il
me rappelle un tout petit peu brejnev
staline compte brejnev vous comprenez
c'est pour ça que je soutient énormément
je suis un soutien soutien
inconditionnel de démarche du président
macron parce que vous avez prononcé un
mot désescalade dans sa dans la démarche
française il y en a deux aspects il ya
la fermeté que vous avez vus mais ils
vous imaginez bien qu à vous taper tout
le temps c'est sûrement sur les marches
sur mâcon vous avez tapé tout sur lui
c'est une folle une courage
extraordinaire pour prendre le téléphone
et téléphoné une heure et demie et
parler avec avec ça parce que la
solution les sanctions je ne crois guère
l'autre l'a dit que le miss france et il
a dit que voit on va mettre le peuple
russe à genoux pour comprendre au niveau
de la mer il et où ils ont vécu ministre
de l'écologie fois dix fois moins bien
bien sûr sous eltsine peut-être il est
sans doute ils vont prendre la moitié
mais simplement il faut qu'on soit
conscient donc l'occe arrivera sans
penser qu'en venez vous pensez que il va
côté dix fois plus cher mais c'est sa
fonction économique pour vous elles
n'apporteront aucune solution
simplement je sais par mon expérience
mais comprenez ce que comment réagissent
les semaines inquiète comment ils font
parce que l'autre tout à l'heure j'ai
parlé avec les américains il me dit ce
soit simple les russes ils vont vivre
mal les oligarques ils font le complot
ils vont virer poutine mais c'est pas ça
qui se passe est ce que tout le monde
attend mais c'est ce que ce canton mais
il faut puisque c'est une hypothèse
assez suivent on est concerné il faut
pas prendre il faut être très
pointilleux dans l'analyse c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe pour l'instant
mais quand il y aura s'il ya des morts
ça peut changer les donnes la donne pour
l'instant c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe j'étais cofondateur de premier
parti démocratique jeu j'ai beaucoup de
sympathie pour les gens qui gueulent
contre la guerre là-bas vous comprenez
mon idée c'est toujours organisé tout de
suite pour aller de la rencontre avec
poutine zelensky pour éviter la prise
d'eau qui a essayé de dieu de nous et ça
me semble que moi je suis lucide et
qu'est ce qu'il nous reste dans ce
contexte là la fermeté que le président
macro à exprimer et le mot qu'ils
utilisent et que vous avez été lésés
messieurs net d escalade dans les
chemins de désescalade parce que c'est
la seule solution pour éviter le pire
parce que vous comprenez le gaz dix fois
plus cher le choc pétrolier à noron la
hervé grandjean porte-parole du
ministère des armées est avec nous ce
soir si vous nous rejoignez à 20h58 on
est on est en direct merci encore un
hervé grosjean d'être avec nous est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire ce soir quel
serait
le meilleur scénario on peut dire qu'ils
puissent y en avoir un et le pire
scénario le meilleur scénario c'est
qu'il ya une cessation des hostilités
très vite et que ukrainiens et russes se
mettent autour de la table et puissent
discuter d'une voie de sortie de crise
aujourd'hui il ya des pourparlers c'est
pas des négociations et de toute façon
on négocie pas avec le pistolet sur la
tempe est ce que demande la france c'est
qu'on arrête les combats d'abord donc ça
c'est le meilleur scénario c'est une
négociation
le pire scénario moi je fais pas de
guerre fiction vous avez prononcé le mot
nucléaire est sûre je crois qu'il faut
rassurer les français et les gens qui
vous regardent c'est important on sait
ce compte cinq mises à feu
il a dit il faut s'attendre au pire
l'histoire c'est pas le ministre des
affaires étrangères en matière nucléaire
il faut rappeler que la france est dotée
d'une force de dissuasion nucléaire donc
c'est quoi c'est concrètement c'est des
sous marins avec bombe atomique et des
avions de chasse qui peuvent aussi
emporté la bombe atomique la dissuasion
nucléaire c'est notre meilleure
assurance-vie pourquoi parce qu on
envoie le message au pays que si un pays
voulait nous attaquer et ben nous on
retour on tour l attaque est encore plus
fort mais il est juste on m'annonce à 10
watts n'importe quelle prise nous
attaquer donc mon message c'est aux
français ne vous attendez pas à le dire
mais les rv et on se parle hervé godard
des grands l'ont justement parce que ça
on en a c'est la question que je pose à
chaque fois on se dit nous on a la
chance d'avoir un président qui a la
tête sur les épaules qui voilà qui qui
va pas partir en vrille et mais la
question qu'on se pose c'est est-ce que
vous l'a dit mir poutine qui est on a
l'impression qu'il est dans une dans une
quête qu'on n'arrive pas à comprendre
est ce qu'il peut dire même si la france
a une arme de dissuasion nucléaire
est-ce qu'ils seraient pas après
peut-être pas sur la france ou sur un
autre pays a montré voilà pour en
exemple de dire voilà je m'élançais une
bombe nucléaire voilà pour montrer que
je suis prêt à tout mais la france n'est
pas en guerre avec la russie mais ça
c'est un film en guerre avec la france
deladrière poutine il a brandi cette
menace nucléaire un peu voilé en disant
qu'il mettait en alerte des forces
armées nucléaire en russie c'est une
menace cas pas grand sens parce que ce
genre de choses on le fait qu'en soi
même on est agressé quand son pays et
agresser quand la magritte et de son
territoire est menacé c'est pas du tout
le cas c'est lui l'agresseur donc c'est
une rhétorique cas pas grand sens et qui
est peut-être un discours un peu
d'inquiétude comme il se rend compte que
la progression de ses forces dites
conventionnelles donc les forces qui
sont pas nucléaire les blindés mais joie
vont pas aussi vite que ce qu'ils
pensaient et peut-être il prend peur ils
s'inquiètent et donc il donne un message
à encore plus de fermeté mais ça ne
correspond à aucune réalité